do you remember the audition for Vampire
Diaries oh dude it was hell how many
auditions dude I'm not exaggerating I've
been doing this for a while I've done a
ton of you know TV pilots and it's
always stressful you know how that [__]
is screen testing and doing the network
in the studio like crap it's brutal this
was the worst experience of my life I
mean I read for Ian Somerhalder's role
first and I got a call back uh then they
then I didn't hear from them I told you
I tested for some other shows and then
they I get a frantic phone call they've
done three rounds of testing they can't
find anybody for this roll of Stefan the
younger brother uh they'll bring you in
uh read for it I went and read for it
they said great you're testing the next
day I went back I went and I showed up
and because it started shooting in a
week they were testing I think 14 guys
I'm not exaggerating they were all there
all there it was uh uh uh they flew two
out from Australia one out from New
Zealand a few out from England
oh yeah uh who because I can name so
many people that I tested with that got
the rolls that I didn't it's so funny
because I actually like at the time was
pretty oblivious to it but I remember
Julie pleck who was the co-creator of
the show ended up telling me one day all
the actors that read from my part and it
was this like incredible list of you
know uh uh you know a-listers and all
these people and anyway so I go in there
and I swear it was like I I mean it was
like uh you know you'd go in you'd read
for it once then they'd be like okay
wait outside then they'd come out with
like a clipboard and they'd be like you
go home and then some guy would be go
home with his bags and then they'd go
and okay read again and they would come
out okay you two go home boom those guys
and it like it was like this like I felt
like I was on Survivor and it was like
dwindled down and suddenly it was down
to like me and just like one dude and um
and then it was the final I mean I think
I read for it like six or seven times
the one good thing about that is that
there was no network it was just studio
and then they decided to film the
audition and send it to the network
um because they just couldn't they had
to get um you know everyone uh to
Vancouver to shoot but I'll tell you I
uh I had a real specific approach which
was Nina who was already cast as the
lead girl was there
and everybody in uh in that audition uh
room during that process was kissing her
ass because she was in the hallways and
she was like everyone was like going up
to her and saying hi and kissing her ass
thinking you know if they ask her who
did you like you know maybe she'll like
me and I was like [__] that I'm not
gonna look her in the eye and I'm also
not going to introduce myself and I'm
not gonna I'm just gonna sit in the
corner because not because I was trying
to be rude but because in the scene we
were supposed to not know who one
another supposed to be a mystery we were
supposed to meet I know it's very
methodical no I like it [__] you it
works we were supposed to meet in uh in
that exact moment and I thought well
[__] that I want our moment to be really
special I want her to get to know me in
that moment and Ira and and Nina
remembers this and I just remember her
like looking over at me wanting to say
hi to me and introduce herself and I
just turned away and I and I think she
thought initially like who the [__] does
this guy think he is but anyway I went
in there and I just remember our
audition the audition and the first time
we ever met in real life was actually in
that audition room and I and it was just
a very magical moment and I felt it wow
and she felt it and I know all those
Studio Executives felt it and I think
that's what landed me the part actually
and then afterwards you say you know
that I was doing this for yeah of course
and she was like and she and she talks
about it in an interview she even says
like Paul was so dismissive and rude and
I didn't know what to make of it but
then in the in the in the audition it
totally worked wow but then you left her
wondering God is he gonna be an [__]
and son right I don't know and then
surprise I was surprised I'm not talking
to anybody I'm in my head